on sort bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de 7,8 échos le magazine consacré à
l'actualité économique de notre
territoire sans plus tarder voici le
sommaire s'engager pour l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes notamment
plusieurs entreprises de notre
territoire ont mis en place des
dispositifs c'est le cas du groupe
l'abord akoa plaisir et de la société
sodexo à guyancourt
jean christophe poulet nouveau directeur
de l'école de la deuxième chance dans
les yvelines sera également en plateau
dans six ans la planète aura les yeux
rivés sur paris mais aussi sur saint
quentin en yvelines qui accueillera
plusieurs épreuves des jeux olympiques
pour que les entreprises du territoire
tirer un maximum de profit le medef a
lancé une plate forme intitulée
entreprises 2024 campagne de financement
participatif pour la start-up
saint-quentinoise qui sait ils ont
encore nouvel appel à candidature pour
intégrer le sli cube
nous ferons un tour d'horizon de
l'actualité économique dans notre
territoire
mais avant de développer tous ces titres
commençons avec un chiffre 85000 euros
c'est le montant de trois conventions de
prêts d'honneur signé il ya quelques
jours entre le groupement d'intérêt
public yvelines coopération
internationale et développement et des
entrepreneurs des et qui vise à
encourager le développement économique
d'entreprises yvelinoise en afrique une
société de transport de poisson frais ou
encore une société de location d'engins
de chantier verront bientôt le jour au
cameroun et au sénégal
le medef a présenté il ya quelques jours
ou au vélodrome nationale la plateforme
entreprises 2024 opérationnel dès le 1er
octobre 2018 elle permettra aux
entrepreneurs d'avoir un accès
privilégié aux appels d'offres liés aux
jo-2000 24 qui se dérouleront à paris
mais aussi sur plusieurs sites de saint
quentin en yvelines
reportage informations sur les jeux
olympiques de 2024 appel à projets appel
d'offres ou encore emploi en lançant la
plateforme entreprises 2024 le medef
souhaite faire profiter les entreprises
de cette opportunité économique le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
sera particulièrement concernée puisque
quatre sites accueilleront des épreuves
le rendez-vous est dans six ans et
pourtant c'est maintenant qu'il faut
anticiper on n'a pas du tout le droit à
l'erreur c'est la planète qui nous
regardent et c'est un vrai facteur de
rayonnement pour la france que d'avoir
l'accueil de ces jeux olympiques
donc on ne peut pas se louper et donc
c'est de la préparation et de la
planification la plateforme entreprises
2024 également dédié aux associations
sera mise en route dès le 1er octobre
2018 pour l'instant aucun chiffre précis
sur les retombées économiques
les jeux olympiques devrait néanmoins
créé 250 mille emplois pour 50 ans avec
les sites qui existent déjà il ya une
part hôtelière il part dans le bâtiment
c'est une vraie opportunité s'il ya un
manque de main d'oeuvre dans certains
secteurs et en mettre en place des
formations en adéquation avec la demande
lors de cette présentation de sportif
françois pervis et quentin lafargue ont
partagé avec les entrepreneurs leur
parcours et leur motivation pour
atteindre le plus haut niveau
quand on est
patron d'une entreprise ou salarié ou
collaborateurs on a des objectifs de
réussite
et forcément quand on est sportif de
haut niveau c'est la même chose tout
comme les sportifs les entrepreneurs
yvelinois pourront mettre toutes leurs
chances de leur côté grâce à cette
plateforme pour profiter au mieux de
l'événement au front à présent le
dossier de cette émission consacrée aux
entreprises qui s'engagent dans
l'insertion
elles sont plusieurs sur notre
territoire a proposé des opérations mais
aussi et des dispositifs destinés à
intégrer et des personnes éloignées de
l'emploi
exemple à plaisir et à guyancourt avec
ses 14 succursales régionales et ses 200
salariés le groupe l'abord aco fait
partie des leaders européens du marché
de la propreté le siège français est
installé depuis plus de 35 ans à plaisir
sur ce site plusieurs activités matériel
de nettoyage industriel ou encore
l'entretien des espaces verts pour
éviter le turnover les ressources
humaines ont mis en place depuis peu un
dispositif d'insertion depuis six mois
maintenant on a en fait mis en place par
l'intermédiaire notamment de la mission
locale en fait des stages professionnels
dans le but d'aider ces jeunes donc qui
sont soit éloigné d'emploi donc à
reprendre une activité affiner un projet
professionnel
l'idée bien sûr de ce stage cdd c'est de
pérenniser ce identique et des
opportunités de le faire donc on a eu
quelques cas concrets des jeunes qui ont
été embauchés en cdd voire en cdi au
service logistique ou en tant que
technicien de maintenance une politique
d'insertion qui présente de nombreux
avantages pour ce groupe tdc vraiment de
créer aussi un vivier et puis de
travailler en local tout simplement
parce que quand aujourd'hui vous
travaillé avec des cabinets de
recrutement aujourd'hui vous pouvez pas
voilà précisé que voulait telle ou telle
ou telle région donc c'est aussi une
façon d'avoir d'avoir en fait un impact
est de faire travailler en tout cas en
local
sa fonction la direction son ancienneté
et ses hobbies c'était en mars dernier
l'entreprise sodexo et la fondation agir
contre l'exclusion lance la deuxième job
academy
le principe pendant quatre mois 28
salariés de cet opérateur de
restauration et de services coach des
demandeurs d'emploi basé à guyancourt
la société emploie 450 mille personnes à
travers le monde 30 me en france depuis
plus de 15 ans elle mène une politique
d'inclusion et de diversité notamment on
travaille avec une association qui
s'appelle c'est possible qui est une
association qui source d'une population
qu'on appelle jeunes décrocheurs
le mois dernier on a accueilli comme ça
deux groupes d'une vingtaine de
deux lycéens et de collégiens pour leur
montrer ce que c'était que les métiers
des services généraux donc la fameuse
maintenance un puisqu'ici on a
évidemment tous les services qui tourne
autour des services généraux et pour
leur permettre souhaite valider un
projet professionnel autour de ces
métiers là ou alors de confirmer qu'il
faut qu'ils s'engagent sur une autre
voie mais le but c'est vraiment de l'est
voilà de leur donner un une vision du
monde du travail et comment ils peuvent
au mieux s'insérer dans le monde du
travail favoriser l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes des détenus
ont encore des handicapés et des
initiatives qui séduisent les salariés
et qui augmentent leur niveau
d'engagement un fait constaté chez
sodexo avec notamment ses job academy
alors que ça leur donne un peu de
travail supplémentaire qui n'est pas
normalement compris dans leur dans
l'eure dans leurs fonctions
bilan il en retire une certaine dehors
choix si c'est une fierté mais en tout
cas ils donnent beaucoup de leur temps
ils reçoivent aussi beaucoup et ils sont
assez fiers de se rendre utile en fin de
compte et ils peuvent donner un petit
peu ce qu'ils ont su à travers leur
éducation ou leur formation roule ou les
métiers qu'ils ont exercé au centre
rexall s'engager dans l'insertion une
démarche gagnant-gagnant pour les
entreprises mais aussi pour les salarié
es avec nous en plateau jean christophe
poulet bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
directeur de l'école delà de l'école de
la deuxième chance du val d'oise est le
nouveau directeur de l'école de la
deuxième chance des yvelines alors je
dis nouveau directeur ans puisque c'est
tout récent puisque ma pensée l'école de
la deuxième chance du val d'oise qui va
reprendre la gestion de l'école de la
deuxième chance d yves hinant c'est bien
ça voilà il ya un partenariat renforcé
entre les deux écoles il ya un président
en commun c'est benjamin school qui
concilie régional qui est président donc
deux de ses 95 et 2 218 je suis
directeur de l'ensemble
alors dans les yvelines il ya trois
sites aux mureaux à magnanville et
attrapes destinée c'était que les
options s'est dessinée à des jeunes de
18 à 25 ans qui n'ont pas de diplôme
mais pas de qualifications qui ont eu un
parcours scolaire qui
diversement appréciable avec des
problèmes parfois qui dépend de
l'orientation mais souvent sur des
problèmes familiaux une erreur de
parcours tout court et ce sont des
jeunes qui ont envie de raccrocher qui
on vit vraiment de travailler nous l'ont
l'adjectif qu'on leur donne souvent
celle et dégourdi on les appelle des
gondi ses rangs des jeunes qui ont envie
de canton vi envie de faire agir
exactement oui alors combien de temps
alors on parle pas de scolarité on va
parler plutôt de formation et bien
l'information elle dure entre 4 et 8
mois
parfois elle peut durer dix à douze mois
mais quand c'est un peu trop long
c'est pas forcément un bon navigateur et
donc les jeunes vont à leur rythme c'est
à dire que s'ils ont besoin de remise à
niveau ben ils se remettent à niveau en
maths et en français
ils font beaucoup de
de d'ateliers autour la technique
recherche d'emploi du cerveau à être en
entreprise savoir s'habiller s'est
reparlé des collaborateurs ca se
positionne entreprises c'est lorsque
c'est que l'entreprise
ils font beaucoup de stages et puis pour
certains d'entre eux on les prépare sur
des modules métiers pour ensuite qu'ils
aillent en entreprise en sachant déjà ce
que fait l'entreprise et donc il ya une
alternance de liens de cours théoriques
et puis au début c'est une alternance
60% au centre et 40 % d'entreprises puis
sadeyen 50 50
et à la fin c'est beaucoup plus
d'entreprises et d'ailleurs au travers
de ces stages les les récents
l'entreprise les rh repères souvent les
jeunes qui les intéressent au pouvoir
les embauches et ensuite il ya vraiment
des partenariats qui sont venus mais
l'entreprise du territoire et puis oui
c'est très important donc à des
partenariats structurants et des
conventions mais les jeunes aux mêmes
tissot de partenariat parce qu'il ya des
jeunes parfois qui font des métiers par
exemple infographie si on n'a pas de
partenaire là dessus et donc on cherche
au travers de jeunes et c'est le jeune
qui nous crée partenariat pour d'autres
qui viennent ensuite parce que vous avez
des difficultés à convaincre les
entreprises de prendre un jeune issu de
l'école de la deuxième chance en stage
non on n'a pas véritablement de problème
à convaincre les entreprises des
entreprises jouent le jeu
montrent aussi des process rse donc pour
pouvoir accueillir voilà on l'a vu à des
salariés qui s'engagent en plus
d'entreprises pour accueillir des jeunes
pour être tuteur de jeunes tournent à
pas et c'est la rencontre qu'on doit
créer en fait on doit permettre déjà
trop en difficulté il faut déjà que nous
on est fait un travail en amont pour que
15 des entreprises savent où ils vont et
puis il faut l'entreprise ne connaissent
pas c'est la rencontre qui doit se faire
mais il faut la rencontre est fait il
n'y a pas de difficulté notoire est ce
que en parlant de chiffres est ce que
vous avez le taux d'insertion dans le
monde professionnel à l'issue justement
de cette formation de quatre et
bin-houin oui alors le la moyenne
nationale du judo 6 et 55 % de sorties
positives repas c'est une soirée
positive soit en formation qualifiante
soit un emploi soit les yvelines sur 60%
mais on va dire que mon une école qui
fonctionne bien c'est plutôt 75 sont 17%
en tout cas c'est l'objectif qu'on a
nous pour les yvelines
merci jean christophe poulet d'avoir été
sur ce plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
le tout nouveau directeur de l'école de
la deuxième chance des yvelines vous
êtes également le directeur de l'école
de la deuxième chance d'y val d'oise un
nouvel appel à candidature pour intégrer
le ski cube ou encore ou une toute jeune
start-up saint quentinois ce qui lance
une campagne de financement participatif
c'est tout de suite dans les coûts en
bresse externaliser la fonction
commerciale des entreprises c'est ce que
souhaite proposer bientôt la start-up
saint-quentinoise qui says
elle vient de lancer une campagne de
financement participatif afin de lever
des fonds une start up qui s'inscrit
également dans une démarche sociale le
problème c'est que on a beaucoup de
petites structures qu'aujourd'hui et se
contente d'un petit marché
et des fois même qui meurent parce
qu'elles n'arrivent pas à se développer
nous on souhaite justement les aider à
passer ce cap on souhaite réserver une
partie des emplois à des personnes qui
ont la reconnaissance de travailleur
handicapé
si une réelle volonté de notre part de
les aider à pouvoir se réinsérer dans le
monde professionnel
le ski tubes lance dès le 23 mai un
nouvel appel à candidature pour intégrer
l'incubateur de saint quentin en
yvelines un lieu dédié à
l'entrepreneuriat est destiné à aider
les jeunes startups et lauréats pourront
bénéficier pendant 24 mois d'un
accompagnement administratif de bureau
ou encore de dispositifs de financement
vous avez jusqu'au 23 juin pour
candidater sur sky entreprise.com
partager une idée une expérience sur le
thème du data bang le 27 novembre
prochain vous pourrez peut-être devenir
intervenant lors de la quatrième édition
de ted et saclay qui se déroulera au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le concept connaît un succès grandissant
et s'adresse aux entrepreneurs aux
doctorants aux étudiants mais aussi aux
passionnés et candidatures sont ouvertes
jusqu'au 27 mai quatre personnes seront
sélectionnées pour cette édition 2010 8
cette émission touche bientôt à sa fin
mais avant voici à quelques rendez vous
économiques qui vous attendent
lundi 28 mai de 9 à 11 heures un atelier
intitulé définir et réaliser soi-même
son étude marché est proposée au ski
cuba guyancourt inscription sur sky
entreprise.com mercredi 30 mai à partir
de 16 heures 30 une conférence sur le
thème des fonds européens aura lieu
également au ski cube à guyancourt
inscriptions elle a aussi sur le site
qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi 5
juin pour un nouveau cette ut co
consacrée ajustements aux fonds
européens
à très bientôt
[Musique]